now we will play the fifa arena
gm
who is also one of the big names here
2700 it's not a joke
bishop c4 okay this is a joke
um i don't know e5 maybe
maybe e4
yeah this is some weird uh
weird french defense coming like he will
play
he'll probably play c4 one day
and then the bishop on b3
will not be too bad
i believe okay c4 how do we
how do we react to such stuff maybe just
b6
yeah take stakes followed by 96 black is
obviously better but
um it is not
i was about to say it is not much but
actually maybe it is much
he sort of paralyzed castling king side
is always dangerous
because of some um some random attack
coming
i'll play b should be just to have a
queen e6
in case of castling short yeah so now he
will just play
bishop d2 roxy one but then he has to
play something
like one day playing with the kink in
the center
could become really dangerous i'm
probably about to play 97 knight f5
knight h4
and to start um yeah attacking his king
size as well
he plays 92 it's probably try
trying to to prepare castling short
anyway but
i mean it does not feel like uh castling
short will ever be
will ever be good enough
place knight h3 okay so what's wrong
with the knight h4
maybe there is nothing wrong actually
place king of one okay then we just take
and play rook s8
activating the rook
yeah he brings the knight two two and
now he will try to play king ju1 h2 i
believe
i'll just go g5 which is not exactly an
attacking move but i'm just trying to
prevent knight f4
okay so he plays knight c3
yeah we have many tempting moves here
you can just play blinking g7 for
instance yeah maybe it is
good enough yeah he has a check but then
i think we've
just taken page six
and now we can we can think of some f504
plans
b should be three don't know where is
this going exactly okay let's try five
he plays bishop d1 yeah this is quite
sad for white i must say
okay let's play uh i mean i have a trick
i can play knight f3
g takes bishop f7 dropping the queen
if he plays bishop takes i can also play
bishop f7 right
yeah so it seems to work which is a bit
surprising but
okay why not
after knight xe4 there is always d takes
e4 and
the idea is still there
seems to work
oh it's sort of a cheapo but anyway
after let's say rookie fate i think it's
very very
very very tough for white f4 is coming
and stuff i mean
it should just be bad
yeah he takes bishop f7
and takes okay queen takes
and he's trying to bring the bishop to
b3
to come up with uh at least some control
play
which now he resigns there will be no
control play
alright thanks for the game